як Україні вдається стримувати Росію
найпотужніша зброя країни цифрові
технології наприклад розвідка на основі
штучного інтелекту дрони та цифрові
карти битви у реальному часі усе це
відіграє важливу роль для успіху України
ось три цифрові інструменти які змінюють
сучасну війну номер один не розвіддані в
режимі реального часу інформація в
режимі реального часу є важливою зброєю
у війні програмне забезпечення отримає
дані з таких джерел як GPS супутники
камери спостереження дрони і навіть
мобільні телефони вони надають
інформацію просили противника та їхнє
місцезнаходження українські військові
можуть користуватися цифровими картами
поля бою на своєму планшеті чи смартфоні
штучний інтелект має вирішальне значення
коли йдеться про обробку великих обсягів
даних і їхні практичне використання
українська армія має для аналізу гори
даних у реальному часі це інформація яка
може врятувати життя якщо її досить
швидко оцінити штучний інтелект також
може допомогти з оцінкою шкоди під час
атаку в режимі реального часу А в деяких
випадках навіть передбачити де ворог
може нане наступний удар український
стартап звук використовує програмне
забезпечення для ідентифікації ракети
гелікоптерів винищувачі від Дронів за
допомогою звукової бази даних обладнання
складається з акустичних дзеркал і
мікрофона шум записується штучний
інтелект ідентифікує джерело шуму шляхом
порівняння та навіть попереджає коли
Атака неминуча номер два українська it
армія війну проти України назвали першою
кібербіною в історії планети Стефан
дуган генеральний директор інституту
Кібер Миру пояснює чому
ніколи раніше кіберпростір не мав такого
значення І такої ваги в контексті
введення війни
інформаційно-комунікаційні технології
справді застосовуються усіма сторонами
конфлікту для досягнення військових
цілей Тобто це зміна правил гри
кібератаки вже зачепили 37 країн
кіберпростір за своєю суттю безмежний
Я думаю саме тому це називається
кібервійною тому що вже набагато більше
країн окрім України та Росії постраждали
від цих кібератак
українці технічно підковані в країні
працює понад 200 тисяч розробників
програмного забезпечення деякі з них
разом із спеціалістами сформували
it-aрмію України міжнародний колектив із
понад 300 тисяч волонтерів озброєних
програмним забезпеченням тепер хакери з
обох сторін атакують критичну
інфраструктуру інститут кібермируженеві
зафіксував у 2022 році понад 850
кібертак пов’язаних з війною Росії проти
України більшість з них були так званими
досатаками або атаками на відмови в
обслуговуванні вони були спрямовані на
паралізацію роботи банків Міністерства
цивільної інфраструктури
якщо подивитися на період із січня по
вересень 2022 року то різко зросла
Кількість атак на Україну Також є
компанія кібера так проти Росії але
кількість явно менше тобто коли йдеться
про Україну ми зафіксували близько 1 800
випадків А на Росію ми змогли
задокументувати 150 кібернападів
цікаво що хакери з анонімось
міжнародного колективу хакерів
активістів борються По обидва боки
анонімось Росія пов'язана з понад сотною
атак тоді як анонімус Україна здійснила
близько 50 кібератак номер три дрони
експерти кажуть що війна в Україні - Це
перша війна в якій безпілотники
використовують в такому масштабі з обох
сторін їх використовують як зброю та для
збору розвідних особливо коли йдеться
про військовий розвідку важливу роль
відіграють цивільні дрони створення для
невійськових цілей після заклику дрони
Люди з усього світу відправили
безпілотники в Україну тепер вони
літають над російськими позиціями та
військовими базами надаючи важливу
інформацію Українській армії
аеророзвідка приватний підрозділ
сформований після початку російської
агресії у 2014 році який складається з
колишніх хаті працівників і
військовослужбовців навіть почав
перетворювати цивільні Дрони на
військові пристрої які можуть внести та
скидати гранати але Україна покладається
не лише на саморобну зброю коли йдеться
про безпілотники якби відро не служить
турецьке безпілотники беєктар тб-2 і
американський Switch Blade У той час як
барректар тб-2 має величезний розмах
крил 12 метрів і може бути використаний
повторно світ Блейд відомий як дронка
мікад оскільки врізається в ціль що
робить його одноразовим
точний інтелект хакерські атаки та дрони
війна РФ проти України назавжди змінює
правила ведення війни Як ви думаєте чи
вирішити технології Хто переможе у цій
війні